[MUSIC PLAYING]
This is the skull of one of the most famous
of dinosaurs, Tyrannosaurus rex.
It's also one of the most intensively studied species.
Yet even so, new discoveries are still
being made about this formidable predator.
Something that continues to fascinate us
is how good they were at hunting.
Key factors in their success were their senses.
So how powerful were their eyes, their hearing, and their sense
of smell?
When we want to understand a little bit about dinosaur
senses, it's really, really difficult.
We don't have any of the sense organs preserved.
But we can get some clues to things like eyesight,
just from the outside of the skulls.
We can look at the shape of the eye sockets.
This gives us some clues as to the size of the eyeball,
and also the directions in which the animal were looking.
T-rex eyes faced forwards, evidence for binocular vision.
And they were huge, the size of grapefruits.
The fields of vision of its two eyes
overlap substantially, giving it very good depth perception,
which would have made it a very effective predator.
In the modern world, hunters like African wild dogs
have superb vision.
But they don't just rely on sight.
Combined with their acute senses of smell and hearing,
they can attract prey from miles away.
Could T-rex do the same?
New medical scanning techniques provide evidence that it could.
CT scanning is something that's really revolutionized our work
in paleontology, and it's giving us
insights that were simply impossible to gain from looking
at the bones themselves.
We can now reveal secrets hidden inside T-rex's brain.
What we can see is that there are
key areas that relate to different senses,
like eyesight and smell.
These are located in specific lobes of the brain.
The bigger those lobes are, the better
the eyesight or the better the sense of smell.
Large optic and olfactory lobes suggest an excellent sense
of sight and smell.
But it doesn't end there.
The inner ear is adapted to pick up
low frequencies, an advantage when detecting
prey over long distances.
These really impressive senses would
have combined to allow them to hone in on prey very
quickly and very accurately.
Now, there's an exciting new theory.
Night vision cameras have revealed many modern predators,
like lions, can use their highly developed senses to hunt
at night.
Perhaps T-rex could do this, too.
Until relatively recently, it was
assumed that dinosaurs were mostly animals of the daytime.
But if we actually look at the behavior of living animals,
there's no reason to think this is true.
Predators can use the cover of darkness
to ambush other animals much more easily.
It's likely T-rex would have made
the most of such an advantage.
Their very, very powerful sense of sight and smell
would have allowed them to hunt prey very, very effectively
in low light conditions, and perhaps even at night.
Modern research techniques mean scientists continue
to make new and surprising discoveries, not only about
T-rex, but many of the other dinosaurs
that lived on our prehistoric planet.